[Music]
if anything goes wrong I'll turn us
around in a heartbeat I know you oh
whoops I like how everyone loves Quicksilver
and in this movie he practically does nothing
he's reduced to a professional seatbelt
unbuckle and a professional taper he's one
of the most powerful x-men and he literally
gets heated out of the movie with ourselves
Charles mr. president are you seeing this
on TV okay hold on a second and the last
movie Charles delivers a message that basically
threatens the entire world but I have returned
the day of reckoning is here and now he has
a personal line to the president what also in
Days of Future past magneto was going to kill
the president and it was recorded live so how
did the x-men have fans they've literally been
threatening the earth countless times even with
mystique this little girl loves her and they're
selling action figures apparently but she tried
to assassinate like some world leaders and she
pointed a gun at a room of like high executives
in the White House after having a little
skirmish in the neighborhood flipping two cars
and destroying the propellers on a helicopter the
government is now cutting ties of the x-men and
setting up interment camps as Xavier I think you
talked to the president they didn't even do this
when the world was almost destroyed eventually
cities urban centers anything built since the
bronze age will be went away hey but a couple
cars get flipped and part of a helicopter he
gets destroyed as screwed dude lock him up
right now it's also funny how they have this
basketball court right above their hangar you're
telling me that anytime they want to leave they
kids have to clear out and stop their game they
have this entire estate and yet they choose the
basketball court like put it anywhere else
there's literally a big clearing right here
and by the way the women are always saving
the men around here you might want to think
about changing the name to ex women oh that was
both very cringy and it doesn't make sense the
women save all the men what about last movie
were Quicksilver saves everyone in the mansion
[Music]
so two mutants are basically tearing
this helicopter in half wouldn't it
be a bright idea to have everyone get in it
so these aliens have the power to like move matter
or something and it's like insta-kill people but
at the end of the movie they just resort to fist
fighting why I think makes perfect sense so it
makes sense because it doesn't make sense in
fact that you're railing about it doesn't make
a lot of sense for this part I need to talk about
a few plot points in the movie gene accidentally
kills Raven and Hank basically loses it and blames
everything on Charles which isn't of itself really
stupid we've been trying to protect these kids
from the world when really we should have been
protecting them from you Jean ghosts Magneto's
camp for shelter and basically just asked him
about vengeance because she's mad at her father
for leaving her when she was young magneto says
I've lived with vengeance my whole life killed
whatever I thought like pain go away didn't so
it's very clear that he denounces vengeance
then literally ten minutes later this happens
when Hank shows up static Jane killed her if
I find her I'll kill her so you're telling me
that after going through a two minute monologue
about vengeance being bad you immediately do a
180 understand so after Raven getting killed
does magneto even like Raven in this timeline
it wasn't like he was trying to kill her in Days
of Future past towards the end the Dark Phoenix
before like the big action set piece in the Train
Charles tries to convince Hank and Magneto to not
kill Jean before the aliens show up and this is me
Jean we can still save her she's still Jean inside
what a compelling argument Hank and Magneto were
so hell-bent on killing Jean for the last half
of the movie and then flip because of Charles's
sorry attempt at being persuasive amazing writing
it's got to be the best writer I've ever seen so
it would seem storm is obviously very powerful
and for most of the movie she just shoots
lightning from her hands and actually shoots
ice cubes at someone it's not till the end of
the movie where she actually uses her powers
Mike used to be a fan so this is the only
interaction that Nightcrawler has with this
guy later on one of the aliens kills him
and Knight collar just goes crazy over his
death for some reason throughout the whole
movie he showed no signs of being bad but he
snaps when someone dies who he doesn't know
at all look at him he's literally crazy now
all right guys this is the most illogical
point in the whole movie how the hell does
this alien know how to walk in high heels let
alone run in them oh god I'm getting Jurassic
world flashbacks alright so we're finally at
the end of the movie and I have no idea what
the hell is happening it's basically just
a light show at this point let me crank up
the brightness I think it'll help you guys
understand what's happening right now my
emotions make me strong hey give it up give
it up the Simon Kinberg what amazing writing
he deserves an Oscar for the screenplay you
guys are gonna mess up my jet ski hold up